こんにちははじめしゃちょー当宿ビザロのことです投手そうです
まあ sony そしてパーティブレイクたんだつので急いでそれゆえまで
嬉しいです
うよああああ
re ある
ああああ
遠藤入りでしょお願いしまーす
ええええええ
というわけでもう日本一のプロチームですよ
今このまま棒材どうしても勝てるだけがナイフ続け今回はこちらー
ポルシェも作りましたーーー
もうウィークなどまつげないと負けるので数なら勝てるんじゃないか
村名に勝つ社員ここまでですはいどーで基本105だと
ドックン数でしょオールしたら一旦火が我々でも部ガールと思ってい
なるほどねやっても勝つでしょやるあーー
雪片ね
ブービーポロしかーしきまーさー
コートがあります不幸とがありますハイボールでたくさんあるんで
これを1回にボールに集めるかポイントだったと生徒ばかり3人決めて
で2人ば防具行って自分ファイアーそうだけどじゃあもう疲れて挙式
じゅんじゅんさすり入るんで junji さん外でやっ
届け狙いましょう関た通りでゴールした落ち葉妻と愛嬌は社員はジャンルって爆発する
って最初応援セーザルべく天井稼いでそうをつけましょう
護衛艦遊びのしてがんばるぞああ
re
ゴール者と氷そやつだったらゴールひとつ確か
のフォーラム入らないので最初約3成功塗っで
疲れてきたら誰が交代するちょっとインタビュー級スキル
ん
今日しゃべりだけじゃべりか比べるだけ端から喋り方で信じる皆殺
[音楽]
雪
さあバスケチーム vs 川崎ブレイブサンダース
いよいよ全台目も世紀の一戦が始まります
ボールを100個使うという試合なんですがまずどのようにして初めて行くんでしょう
か
そうですねまずあのジャンプボールのボールがないのでこれまずやる必要があるかどう
かというところがポイントですね
但沼キャプテンが1
ボールを持ってはいニック選手そしてはじめ選手
愛の女どーっとあっはいせず逃げていきますこれなんですか何やってごらんを早速
破片が多いまで無視してシートに行きましたねもう一つじゃないからので関係ないと早
な形だけで灰を去っすぐもう
先制していくと俳優展開する12体でまだこれで入ってないか
ようやくさん
でも返しましたあそこでかなりうち武蔵良かったかーぼーるとバッティングしました
ハイボールがこのね二つありますのでうん
ボールの支配ずご覧くださいはいほとんどのこれがこっちにありますか
これ効果ランダム選手などがどんどんと相手のチーム上るを奪う動きいいですねー
まぁちょっと頭のプレイですねさあ試合開始30秒が経過しましたはいは通話に買わ
せれば逆転に成功するという展開でいつのまにもあって馬ですね
あれこのシュートは精度に差があるとそうでこれですかね張り pro 3ポイント
入るんでー
結構差がついちゃっても入っに画面でご覧頂きましたハイダーを選手が後ろのほうか
このようにディフェンスへせっせとはいとかいるしゃべりで頑張ってくれたねー
ただ奪ったボールを戻して反映してだけどっちボードしているかのような本数
いい立場だと思います堕落のキャップのホールしかったバスケットボールではかなり
重要なポジションの重要ですねこれは100個バスケの申し子といってもいいしれませ
んねえそしてシューターは館%
はじめしゃちょーかはいそして地面ツアー学生ちょっとサボっているようにも見えます
けども
さあ試合ます澄んできてかなり幸運も
逆に控え左右を盛り上げてみたんですけどここで藤井ペイジが僕のハイボール全部とっ
ていくんだよええ
ちょっとこれは肇社長もう186センチありますけれども同じぐらい性の高いという
ことで抹茶今にボールが内によっていくと
これはい全然生徒集とか a オレで弾かれるということになったんでしょうか
やってますねーさあこれですか冊肇社長
time タイムアウトを使っていました検査は嫌いじゃないんですけども体力的な
限界を感想ですかかなりまだ序盤ですけれども大丈夫ですか2分経過していないところ
でそっと1回ここで作戦を考えます
ん
ni
持っています
ああああああ
かいっぱい線西飾磨監視してるのって
いやーめっちゃいいせんですけどこのはいくとプロはていうかですねー
のっけます
ブービー j
んええええ
さあ試合が再開ですはいどのようにして参加していくんでしょうこれは俺もよくわかん
なかったねかーっ
そこで川崎の店主が全員ほぼディフェンスに入ってますねうん何個まとめ買いがあるん
でしょうか
試合はぬるっと始まりました付けるっ子さあここで上りが8分というところでパー萩野
選手は続々と豪雨無人内に集まってきてボールを奪っていくという層の3年生が結構つ
に熱くなってるねー
重いてよくあるじゃないなんとかもルーバー済んだぞナースリーが入りべきて大
どうしようもないですねばなぁこの xs と高い壁があります彼はティ
ただペースみてくださいだ言って安いんですよねそうですねー
すぐにこの本当にシーソーゲームとルーところですねー
さあ試合もの鳥がなぁ37ところっと
使ったでしょうかファールをクリックしましたが jun 13
さあこの試合には審判はいませんご了承くださいぞ
パターまあここまでは良く前世シティという
伸ばすチーム入ったと見てきたこの日は g かつニックですペットからも純ファイル
ですよ
これもう
源さんをコーディ別に行きますけれどもどんなことをするっていつ見てくださいはい
設定マッハ待たせてますねただおやおや
おっとあるニック選手これちょっとアレなお産差し始めさんもディフェンスいきます
けどもゴールしたでこれ一人でしやー
自分にとってレーンはちょっと迷いでいいところスターターいる
状態ですぞーてればいい人バエもずるい俺はもう
源貞山に30歳以上になってしまいました
ここでタイムアウトですやっちゃいました体力的にも我々結構ギリギリだったんだ
ただまだ半分も立っていないところですただちょっとニック選手のあの破壊力で
エンサーが結構いらっしゃいましたねー
voodoo
さあ試合再開ですこの試合再開の場面だけは無駄にちゃんとしてますねはいすごいん
ですけどね
見て連続でやっぱり pot ここもきれいに決めていきました
まあ今と少し差が縮まったという厚いチームそしてダンサーした蔵王使っていくはい
パニック選手にはまるで意味がないよ餌法律家ましたのですね鬼に金棒とは行きます
んでしたそして各選手はこう直属時にも決めていると嬉しいです
なかなか工房学校激しくなってきて展開があんまり縮まらないですねそうですね入って
きます少し厳しいかもしれませんそして若干ではありますが
オールなぁ校減ってきたような印象もありますのでコートを見るともうないんすよこれ
アロングシュート0
これは相当なない今日は生まれました
そしてニック政治が高い練習に来なくてちょっとこれどうするも関根選手も対応できる
どうすんねんこれもさあ
バスケ c 200体を前にして足踏みという展開になりました
さあゴールもない
さあここで体力の限界でタイムアウトブザーが鳴り響きました愛助かりました
みてくださいもう我々皆帆何でもほぼ
そうですね歩けない相撲もうちょっとだを選手に関しても生命の危機すら感じるような
いろんな予想です
じゃ
あんこ34ます
yeah
さあ再び試合再開です残り3分を切っていますけれどもはい曲面かなり進歩になってい
ますそれでももうシュート決めるしかないんで外観シュート決めて言ってますみんなで
サーフ
追い上げていくでしょうかに来てきたーっ tonic グッダール5リーダーでも
なんだかみんなで各コーナー starless 入らばいいという展開をそそられる
んですよ
ブーバー先はリードしていますので
ロスもないとああっあれブーバーンぬふつーまーすっとボール夏試合ですねこれもう
ありますかじゃあちょっと
うーんバスで10分も活用がないんじゃないでしょうかですねプロとの試合をちょっと
苦しい部分あると思うんですけども
例えばうまく節水ましたね
体力限界のな選手でありますが別に決めていました
ただここで美麗3戻れないという
いやー濃い苦しいですよなかなかありこそ率先してレースに戻って言うんですよ
新国セグ取られちゃうんですね彼がもう
これ苦しいんですけどなんとか奪い返して件数を
を縮めたいところですそうですねなんとかこのうち6チェスター16点差というと
盛り上げられるかさん断線し楽しいのシュート
もう一度よすげぇ体食べるまだちゃんとありますよはい
さあポリ40秒を切りましたここからどうも言われていくんでしょうか
なかなか厳しいですの利点してが中
もうコッホにっおいをのズレヒート20んが入るってなんだよもう
それはもう弄ばれているような形になりましたうバスケチーム
時間がなくなってしまうのが恋さあ取った
きますカンパ選手宣誓のパッセそして運玉さん
ああ
yeah 一番だパンですが高さを通りございました
そして再び後フェンスですはい幸を突破して秋冬
入らないスターにリバウンドを決めてだろう使用します
残りのも楽分でますやばいー
まあ温度クーラーってしまいました終了になるんでしょうか俺もゴールないですねー
ビッグ x ずになろうかというところ夫というのはからボールわー
ブーバーそろそろ
感じも切ってますか頑張ればず em また経営者の元になった毛はいけるか
ランディムースを以上に変え川崎遠目から順次せしめられます入らない
はい me to do を教えるとハイライン65入ってますもうちょい
いやー俺今お前です
筆者が zero ano hi ni
ああああああ
over me
ni
見つかった
104みたいに139結構
接点ですねよくやりましたねただこの稼ぎたい人たちを歩いていますがもう運バスケ
自慢疲弊したということになりました
ってを抜いてくださってありがとうございましたありがとうございました
[音楽]
ブーバーし